press can help you achieve your goals
quickly you'll want to have writers and
tech magazines mentioning you to help
spread the word about your products if
you can getting a tweet a public
donation or a mention from a relevant
celebrity or opinion leader that
supports your product can be a huge help
working with a pr firm can be expensive
but might be worth considering if you
have a big bang launch like a
kickstarter campaign or any other
specific launch date that you want to
create a big buzz around pr firms can
help you get big names reporters or
celebrities to promote your business
however if it's too early for your
startup to spend budget on pr you can
always do it yourself
if you choose to do it yourself you'll
want to start by writing a paragraph
that you'd like writers to write if you
could have them write whatever you want
this will help you clearly identify how
you want your company to be presented in
the press check out the instructor notes
for an article on tips for how to do
this and let's see what talisar has to
say about pr in the early stages of a
start-up
hi i'm tali starr i'm the founder and
ceo of rooster
before starting rooster i spent four
years at google i was on the marketing
team and i was part of the founding team
that started a program called google
engage which i developed today into
google partners which is a global
program
i left google i came to silicon valley
and i was first employee for a startup
called honeybook and then i started my
company rooster a year and a half ago
rooster is a paid forward movement we're
building a local network that brings
people together to help borrow and share
with one another completely for free in
their local communities so the idea is
you the idea is you join rooster in your
location and you create a profile you
have your real identity there and then
the rules are you can ask for whatever
you need or and help whenever you can
but it has to be for free so people use
it to hand down used furniture and items
they don't need like sofas tvs art
supplies they borrow baseball bats and
baby cribs from one another they walk
each other's dogs they help each other
fix their bike chains and things like
that
we're currently launched in three cities
with thousands of users and a lot of
them use it daily and meet each other
and have all these great experiences
starting with pr with low budget
it's funny a lot of startups operate
under the assumption that doing pr is
this really complicated thing and you
have to build personal connections with
all the reporters and you have to kind
of be in the scene so that they'll want
to write about you
in my experience not true at all
um pr and journalists
you know this is their job is to get
these stories
and all you need to do is kind of
understand their world and where they're
coming from and know how to pitch them
and
have an interesting story to tell right
so you want to have a product that's
interesting enough you want to have some
kind of traction or some kind of story
something that you know can make a news
story and you'll know when you have it
and then you just want to be very
thoughtful of the journalists time so
you want to research who your
journalists are that cover your space
that will potentially be interested in
this don't go and pitch you know a
thousand irrelevant people and once you
have those people
just write in a very clear and concise
way and just consider that they're
getting hundreds of emails per day and
you have to grab their attention first
right so just write a very compelling
title write a very clear and concise
pitch about why this should be
interesting to them and just go and do
it go and reach out to all these people
and in my experience you know i got
great stories in local press and in the
tech countries of the world and and
everywhere i wanted just by you know
giving the right person the right story